[Music]
Priyanka Chopra says she was tricked
into talking about her friend Megan
Markel and her upcoming Royal Wedding
scammed into it actually the actress was
a guest on wednesday's Tonight Show at
the Jimmy Fallon or she explained how
she got quote scammed into talking about
Megan's may 19th nuptials to Prince
Harry because everyone's like do you
know what you're wearing to the next
month you have all these events and I
was like I'm trying to figure it out so
I sort of may have got little scammed
when et caught up with Priyanka on the
quantico set in February she kept the
speculation swirling when attending a
high-profile British wedding would you
wear a fascinator in a hypothetically
British in a hybrid oh hi yeah I may or
may not be going to right I don't know I
haven't thought about it because the
hypothetical wedding isn't coming to
mind like my thing of things but yeah
maybe I would yeah bring it back
regardless Priyanka told Jimmy she's
just thrilled her friend found love but
you know more than anything
forget attending or not I'm just really
happy for a friend of mine like it's a
big day for your friend and you should
be happy about it
[Music]
[Applause]